the whole tech side of the internet is
going crazy over the leaks and rumors
for next year's macbook lineup since the
current lineup makes absolutely zero
sense with a killer value macbook air
for a thousand dollars than a terrible
value 1300 macbook pro which many people
agree shouldn't even exist and then a
massive 700 price gap going up to the
new 14 inch macbook pro for 2 000
but to make things even worse mark
german just came out with an extremely
controversial report claiming that apple
is not only adding another new m2
macbook air to the lineup but they're
upgrading the entry-level macbook pro
again with the same exact m2 chip
basically making it seem like the most
confusing report ever with many people
flat out saying that mark is wrong but
don't worry i've been giving this a lot
of thought and i think that i've finally
figured it all out so let's get right
into it first off mark german's report
says that five brand new macs are coming
in 2022 including a high-end imac an
updated mac mini and a new mac pro with
apple silicon all of which we've already
made full deep dive videos on so
definitely check them out if you haven't
already but in this video we've got to
discuss the 2022 macbook lineup because
everything else seems to make sense
compared to the macbook side which seems
like it's about to get more extensive
and confusing than ever before mark
german says that there's going to be a
new version of the entry-level macbook
pro which is something that many people
weren't expecting because the current
entry-level m1 model doesn't really have
a place in the lineup and i agree it
doesn't it's 300 more expensive than the
macbook air and it's not really much
faster at all in fact there are only a
few benefits like a touch bar which
nobody likes anyway a slightly brighter
500 nit display slightly better
microphones a faster 61 watt power
adapter and cooling fans which don't
really improve performance that much so
for the past few months especially after
the new m1 macbook pros were released
we've been literally telling people to
just buy the m1 macbook air instead of
the m1 macbook pro since you can get it
on sale right now on amazon for 900 and
get it shipped before christmas using
the link below and then if you really
want a macbook pro we've been telling
you guys just to go straight for the 14
inch for 2 000
completely skipping out on the m1
macbook pro altogether so the big
question is this why is mark german
saying that there's going to be a
refreshed macbook pro and how is it
going to fit into the 2022 macbook
lineup especially alongside the brand
new redesigned m2 macbook air which
everyone is so excited about so let's go
ahead and try to break it all down and
thankfully mark german has some older
reports that help piece this puzzle
together a few months back mark told us
that the entry-level macbook pro is
actually going to be getting the same
new m2 chip that's going to be going
into the macbook air which makes total
sense and then on top of that mark
german said that the new air will be
sold alongside the current m1 macbook
air so that means that it will not be
replacing it so it's simply going to be
a new more expensive m2 macbook air
model while the m1 model will likely
stick around at the same 999 price point
for another year and this actually makes
a whole lot of sense for apple to do
because it's exactly what they did in
2018 when they revealed the new
redesigned macbook air for
11.99 and still kept the old thick
silver bezel model around for a full
year at a 999 dollar price point and
then in 2019 apple dropped the base
price of the newly designed 2019 macbook
air by a hundred dollars so it started
at 10.99 while fully discontinuing the
old 999 dollar model and then finally in
early 2020 they released a new intel
based macbook air at that same
999 price point from before so over the
course of a couple of years apple
essentially phased out the old thousand
dollar macbook air and brought the newly
designed model down to that same
thousand dollar price point and i think
that's exactly what apple is gonna be
doing with the new m2 macbook air
releasing it at a higher price at first
while keeping the same old m1 macbook
air at 999
so the big question is this how is apple
gonna price both the new m2 macbook air
and the pro to make them make sense in
terms of a decent macbook lineup because
it's currently a bit confusing with the
m1 pro not really being worth it so what
is apple gonna change this time around
to actually make the m2 macbook pro
worth the extra cash over the m2 air
because in my opinion the pro absolutely
has to cost more than the air contrary
to the belief of some people who think
apple will be releasing a more expensive
15-inch macbook air which is based on
some old rumors and mark german has
already said that apple was thinking of
creating a 15-inch air but they
completely scrapped that idea and
they're not gonna do it anymore and if
you think about it a new macbook pro has
always been more expensive than a
macbook air it just makes sense from a
naming point of view so the main thing
we've gotta answer is how much the new
m2 macbook pro is gonna cost and why
would somebody pay the extra cash for it
over the air because recent reports are
already showing the new air to be a
killer upgrade with a full redesign that
looks absolutely beautiful and ming
choco fully believes that it's getting a
new mini led display which is actually
pretty surprising putting even more
pressure on the m2 macbook pro well for
starters apple could add in the same
benefits that the current m1 macbook pro
has over the m1 air like battery life
cooling fans to stop thermal throttling
a slightly brighter display slightly
better speakers and microphones and a
faster charging adapter but in reality
those differences alone aren't enough
because the current m1 pro is not worth
it compared to the air so the new lineup
obviously needs more differences for it
to make sense so let's get into the
changes that i personally think are
enough to make the future m2 macbook pro
worth it over the air first off i fully
believe that the new model is going to
be getting a full redesign just like the
m2 macbook air because if it sticks to
the current design absolutely nobody
would buy it over the new air it simply
makes no sense so with that said i think
it totally makes sense for the new m2
macbook pro to get the exact same
display and design as the 14 inch m1 pro
macbook pro the only difference would be
the lack of maybe some of the ports like
for example maybe one less thunderbolt
port or maybe the removal of the hdmi
port or something like that yes that
would obviously suck but it would push
people to spend more cash on the 2 000
m1 pro macbook pro which apple loves to
do on top of that i think this new entry
level m2 macbook pro would stick with
that beautiful 14 inch display with
120hz pro motion technology while the
new m2 air would likely only have a 13
inch display without the super thin
bezels and without 120hz promotion so
that display difference alone might be
enough to make people spend the extra
cash on the m2 macbook pro and then
finally we've got to talk about that new
m2 chip and the differences we'll see
between the air and the pro macbooks
mark german has already said that the m2
chip will essentially be the replacement
to the m1 with the same eight core cpu
with four high performance cores and
four efficiency cores but it's gonna
have a faster gpu with either nine or
ten gpu cores instead of the m1 that
goes up to eight with only seven on the
base model and one macbook air so i
think apple is gonna do exactly that
they're gonna give the m2 macbook air a
9 core gpu at the base model while
giving the mt macbook pro the full 10
gpu course and if you didn't already
know the current fanless macbook air
actually does throttle the performance
of the m1 chip a little bit so with the
m2 chip having more gpu cores the
macbook pro might actually have a
noticeable jump in performance next year
and then on top of that if the m2
macbook air gets off-white bezels like
all of the rumors are pointing to then
some people would gladly pay the extra
cash just to get the black bezels that
they prefer so with all that said there
are actually going to be some very good
reasons to go for the new macbook pro
over the air with the biggest one being
the 14 inch display with promotion and
just like that it now finally makes
sense for apple to keep the entry level
macbook pro around as a stepping stone
going up to the 2 000 m1 macbook pro
since the current 700 gap is way too
large to make any sense at all so with
that said let's get into my predictions
for the pricing of apple's entire 2022
macbook lineup we of course have the m1
macbook air which i think is going to
stick to the same exact 999 starting
price because it's still a great deal
and i think that's apple's magical
number for a starting macbook and then i
think the brand new redesigned m2
13-inch macbook air will be priced at
either 11.99 like what they did in 2018
or potentially up to 12.99 if they want
to raise their price points because of
supply chain and inflationary issues and
then of course you've got the m2 14-inch
macbook pro which i think will be priced
at either 13.99 or 14.99 and yes i know
that's a hundred to two hundred dollars
more expensive than the current m1 model
but if you think about it you're going
to be able to get that awesome new
design with the 14 inch mini led display
with 120hz promotion at five to six
hundred dollars less than the current
two thousand dollar m1 pro macbook pro
which i bet a lot of people would pay
for so this would essentially create a
smaller gap between the lower end m2
macbook pro and the 2000 14-inch macbook
pro just like in the past when the base
model was thirteen hundred dollars and
the high-end model was eighteen hundred
dollars and yes i fully believe that
apple is not going to be upgrading the
current 14 and 16 inch m1 pro macbook
pro models until
2023 so those will be staying in the
lineup next year but i do want to
emphasize that apple is going to make it
super tempting to just buy the 2 000
model because i fully expect the m2
macbook pro to start with only 256 gigs
of slower storage not the crazy 5000 to
7000 megabytes per second ssds that the
m1 pro models have and it's only gonna
have eight gigs of slower ram not the
insane 6200 megahertz lp ddr5x that the
m1 pro chip uses so just by upgrading to
a 512 gig ssd and 16 gigs of ram you'll
essentially be only 100 to 200 off of
the price of the high-end m1 pro macbook
pro depending on what they priced the m2
model at which is exactly what apple did
in the past with their intel max so if
you look at everything from this
perspective which is based on what apple
did in the past this new 2022 macbook
lineup makes total sense and this time
around it makes even more sense for
apple to have an entry-level macbook pro
so there you go those are my thoughts on
the new 2022 macbook lineup if you
totally disagree with me then go ahead
and comment your thoughts down below but
if you enjoyed this video go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
one of those two right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]